tourists have traditionally been
fascinated by the islands beauty nature
and local customs they're particularly
drawn to the mixture of Arab ottoman and
African influences that can be found
here lamu city is a UNESCO World
Heritage Site it's also home to a
regular culture festival for gali mood
ha the event is a particular highlight
he's a woodcutter who lives off his
handicrafts but tourism has been
dropping and he's been making fewer
sales now there are plans to build a new
harbour Mimi wha I personally think that
the harbour will bring more business
wanna cause is abian but others aren't
so sure because we are most aware
fishermen and the fish when they make
that boat will destroy all the fish and
this is so and we if you can get job
most of the youth will be fine a
speedboat can reach the mainland in just
15 minutes back in 2014 dozens of people
lost their lives when al-shabaab
militants attacked villages here now
there are plans to build a harbor a
pipeline and an international airport
it's part of a transport and
infrastructure project known as lop set
when complete it will be Kenya second
largest transport corridor the harbour
will contain 32 docks and will be built
by a Chinese firm the airport will be
built on traditional grazing grounds
until last year they belong to the
community but then the Kenyan president
declared the entire Lamu region national
property at their annual meeting the
Shepherd's of lamu discussed fears that
their grazing grounds would be taken
away from them Diotima bring Union about
rich people from outside have the title
deeds so some twitch and deflate claim
to the land now those title deeds will
have to be considered the local
government is trying to secure job
guarantees for the locals
but environmentalists say it's not
enough they reject the mammoth project
under suing the Kenyan government why
you put the garlic in upon your Mambo
the government is acting without first
investigating if this project will have
positive or negative impact and the
corruption will affect future
generations nando here corruption
imbroglio pequeno west Ababa Hakuna
gwangalli a future yeah visethi when the
harbor is complete the docks will
stretch across to the islands and will
close off the canal many mangrove
forests and coral reefs will disappear